foreign
professor of Science and religion at
Oxford University so you studied science
at University partly out of a desire for
certainty you wrote in your article for
II news how did the discovery of the
history and philosophy of science change
your mind about how much certainty there
actually is in science
well I was studying science in the sixth
form of school I I took the view science
was the most reliable way we had
understanding our world and not
something that was reliable that it gave
us certain knowledge of things and I
like that idea you know we all want to
be sure about things then I read a book
by Bertrand Russell the history of
Western philosopher and he said this and
it made me rethink he said the task of
philosophy is to teach us how to live
with uncertainty without being paralyzed
by hesitation and Burton Russell
Wilson's job you know he clearly had
seen that there was an issue here that
in many areas of life we had to in
effect recognize we couldn't have
certainty and that really opened the way
to thinking about this more so I looked
at the history and philosophy of science
and Russell was right you know in effect
science is very very good at pointing us
towards good answers but didn't always
get us there
but even if there isn't like a hundred
percent certainty within science
um does that mean that you would put
more certainty on like you you'd see
certain um evidence or certain
scientific
um narratives as being more certain than
other narratives given that it's more
it's an empirical sign yeah I think
science at the moment is dominant by the
philosophy of inference to the best
explanation and that means you look at
all the observations you say what are
the possible explanations and which
seems to be the best and you can usually
work that out the simplest or the most
elegant but the best isn't always the
right and the right maybe something it
hasn't come along yet so there's always
this element of hesitation this element
of uncertainties a lot of provisionality
in science which means that science is
on a journey and we're at this point in
the journey and in 10 years time being a
different point of things may look
different
there are obvious conflicts between the
narratives that science and religion
have on certain issues for instance with
the creation story
how do you reconcile the two well there
are indeed some conflicts between
science and religion for example in
relation to Creation narratives but
you've got to bear in mind that if I was
talking to a hundred years ago that we'd
be talking about the scientific
consensus that the world has always
existed there's no such thing as a
beginning and of course we're talking
about the beginnings of the universe and
you can see immediately that while a
scientific Narrative of origination and
the religious Narrative of creation are
not the same this kind of way
interesting space level of dialogue but
you're right I mean there are real
tensions between science and religion as
there are between every intellectual
discipline I see this as being creative
you know they open up really good
questions for discussion
so do you embrace one narrative or the
other or you're just interested in the
dialogue between them I try to inhabit
with the scientific and the religious
narrative and that means that some
sometimes I step into one sometimes step
into the other but I'm always asking how
can we bring these into conversation how
might they enrich each other so if you
like it's all about trying to develop a
bigger picture of life then either of
those can give on their own
and are there certain
um current scientific kind of accepted
truths that um or theories that you are
a bit skeptical of I think the model by
which we calculate the age of the
universe is open for radical revision
there are so many issues with it and
basically at the moment we all think the
universe is about nearly 14 billion
years old but that's not based on
observation that's about observations
being interpreted in the theoretical
context that theoretical context I think
is going to change over the next 20
years and then we may have a different
age for our universe which is very
exciting
it's very interesting and on a more
personal level you used to be an atheist
and then you converted to Christianity
what sparked this transformation this
change of mind well I used to be an
atheist when I was at high school and I
was studying science and it was really
wonderful but I took the view that
science and religion were
irreconciliably opposed and also I grew
up in Northern Ireland and in Northern
Ireland back in the 1960s we had
religious violence and so it seemed to
me if there was no religion then a
certain knowledge be no violence that's
a no-brainer so it seemed to me just
obvious that that was the way things
were I think I began to realize that
things weren't quite that simple for
example studying the philosophy of
science made me realize that actually in
many areas of life we have to make
decisions we cannot prove to be right
for example in ethics and politics and
so on I began to realize actually maybe
maybe Faith was something you had to get
used to because there are a lot of
things you just cannot prove and yet
they are so important that didn't
convert me or anything but it kind of
went together a bit more complicated
than I had originally thought and so I
began this process of exploration which
actually made me realize atheism at
least in my view wasn't as productive
and interesting as perhaps Christianity
was so I I moved from one to the other
but I don't anyway criticize atheism I
just say I think I found something
better and I'm happy to have a
conversation about this
um so what did you find in Christianity
that was more productive and better
that's a very good question what I find
in Christianity was a big picture of
life this idea that you stand back and
there is this bigger picture of which
each individual part is important that
gave me a framework for integration
science
religion ethics quest for meaning the
Quest for understanding is all part of
something that is in effect one and the
same and Jeffy like gave me this this
unified Vision which helped me to see my
own existence and also everybody else in
a new way so if you like it was an
expansion of my intellectual Horizons
and you mentioned um your your past view
that um you saw the violence in Northern
Ireland as um being sparked by religion
have you changed your mind about what
actually sparked that violence I think
although back in the 1964 this is
religion that's causing all this
violence I think when you look at more
closer they're clearly political and
economic issues there and maybe religion
is being used as a badge for some deeper
unease that gave rise to this violence
do you think that's the case with other
forms of violence that involve um
religion for instance in other areas of
the world
um like with terrorist groups
um using Islam and is it similarly the
case that you you see that as just a
badge being used for other
um other actual reasons for why this is
happening I think we're always looking
for a higher motivation for doing things
and it can be religion or it can be an
ideology like Marxism or Nazism and so
my concern really is to ensure that
people are able to hold political views
or religious views but not ones that
lead them to kind of extremist actions
that we're seeing in our world today I
don't know how we do that but it needs
to be done and actually there's no
necessary link between religion and
violence it seems to happen that we can
find some ways of breaking that link I'd
be a very happy man and then similarly
um to the question on science and what
you're skeptical of in current science
are you skeptical of certain ideas
within Christianity itself
I think I'm skeptical about everything
in the sense that I always want to know
why doesn't we think that well the
reason for thinking that and and some
beliefs I think can be challenged others
you challenge them I think actually that
seems quite robust in case of
Christianity I mean you're always saying
this is really the best way of making
sense of the New Testament or the Life
of Christ or whatever it is so there's
always that critical spirit but you have
to kind away realize you can't be a
Perpetual skeptic because you you don't
believe anything so what you're looking
for is always what seemed to be the most
reliable beliefs that you can use as a
basis for Meaningful existence in this
world
so if you were to give an example
if something is skeptical of in
Christianity or there isn't anything
within that narrative that um I think
there are always things in Christianity
or indeed in any worldview that you're
going to ask hard questions about and
for me I'd want to ask for example
whether the idea you find in so many
Christian thinkers that God cannot
suffer because God is perfect well I
mean where does that come from I mean it
seems to me that actually God cares this
world so much that God is actually
affected by the world he created
suffering in this way so there's a
conversation that has begun and I feel
quite strongly about it so you've talked
about
um the amazing impact that religion has
um in helping you kind of lead a more
productive kind of life and have a world
view that helps you move forward
um
would you see this as a rational or kind
of irrational use of of religion and to
what extent is religion rational in your
in your mind
I have a question of rationality in
religion is really interesting as indeed
the question of rationality as a whole
is really important one of the things
I've realized through my own research
but also just through reflection on this
is actually each area of life whether
it's science or ethics or religion
really develops its own distinct
rationalities way of approaching the
world its way of formulating questions
as ways of actually getting answers and
what I've realized is that each area of
our inquiry into the meaning of life or
the way the world Works uses different
methods and therefore although this may
sound strange I use one rationality when
I'm doing science another one I'm
thinking about ethics another way I'm
thinking about religion and I can't
always see these as necessary because of
their debt to Identity the topics and
the question really is how I can bring
these back together each method in
effect give me something I can build up
into a bigger picture of life so how are
these methods different and what do they
have in common then I think these
research methods are different and that
they're trying to relate the objects
under investigation so for example in
physics you'll have a very great
emphasis on the importance of the
empirical method as we look at our world
in ethics you're asking how can we live
a good life how what is good how do we
ask those questions in religion very
often what is the meaning of life and
how do I become fulfilled people now
these actually interlock these questions
you can imagine but actually you get to
the answers by different means so
science is not going to be able to tell
us what is good or indeed what the
meaning of life is any more than
religion could tell us how far the moon
was away what the value of Planck's
constant is so it's a question of in
effect recognizing each area has its own
distinct contribution to make but also
its limits how do we bring them together
to give us something that's meaningful
and helpful is there any idea you've
recently changed your mind on
like you asked a good question isn't it
um I used to think that there was this
thing called reason which was absolutely
homogeneous and irrespective of your
cultural context or what you were doing
it was the same thing I think in the
last five years I've realized it's not
that simple but actually reason is
culturally embedded it engages in
different questions in different ways
and in many ways the question is how can
we arrive at a framework for allowing us
to reason cross-culture it's a difficult
one but it's an important one and um is
there a thinker that has influenced you
a lot and would you be able to present
one of their ideas is in just under 10
minutes I've been influenced by many
thinkers and it's so wonderful to have
this but I'm going to single out Mary
Midgley the wonderful English
philosopher who died recently and it's
sorely missed out to say she was a
character a really interesting person
but also had some wonderful ideas and
she says look reality is so complex we
need multiple maps to try and make sense
of its different aspects you know
there's one map from science he's
another from ethics another religion and
we've got to try and do superimpose
those maps and get the most we can out
of them I think that's a wonderful idea
I'd love if unfortunately I can't do
this if she were here to ask her how do
we draw those Maps but I know what she
means and I think it's helpful drawing
Maps getting them right and then putting
them together and seeing the bigger
picture that emerges from those
individual Maps
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV